[Musica]
[Applauso]
grazie sono un esinese e sono orgoglioso
di esser esinese sono un fisioterapista
esperto del sistema di movimento e la
mia più grande passione è la montagna ai
have a dream è una frase di martin
luther king
ho un sogno è bello avere dei sogni ma
per me la cosa più importante è credere
in un sogno perché perchè il sogno è
avere la visione di ciò che è possibile
cambiare di ciò che è possibile
realizzare e qual è il mio sogno il mio
sogno è quello di poter trasmettere ai
colleghi fisioterapisti ai pazienti che
muoversi bene nella giornata è la chiave
per non avere dolore sarebbe bellissimo
che ognuno sulla porta di casa scrivesse
questa frase muoversi bene per vivere a
lungo senza dolore e così ogni mattina
quando esce legge questa frase
probabilmente durante la giornata
cercherà di star seduto in maniera
corretta
cercherà di muoversi in maniera corretta
e vi racconto un po com'è andata la mia
storia
alle elementari non studiavo un molto
mi piaceva andare sui monti coi nonni
avevo imparato a mungere a falciare il
fieno a riconoscere il nome degli
animali e degli uccelli e in
quell'ambiente mi sentivo fortemente
libero quando ero a casa
facevo disperare allora la sera i nonni
o le persone che vi venivano passare la
serata perché la televisione non c'era
raccontavano delle storie delle storie
che incutevano paura
avevo paura ma li ascoltavo i vecchi
parlavano il dialetto pochi oggi sanno
parlare il dialetto pochi oggi sono
ripetere il famoso scioglilingua esinese
quanta cresa chaka chaka chaka chaka
fhfa cresa choc
comunque nel periodo scolastico fin
dalle elementari non ho mai studiato non
ho mai preso dei bei voti
ho finito il liceo sono passato col
minimo dei voti
mi mancavano le motivazioni il perché
perché dovevo studiare perché ero
obbligato
e a me obbligarmi non piace molto poi
dopo liceo venne il militare e militare
mi dette l'opportunità di coltivare la
mia grande passione la montagna quella
passione che mi aveva trasmesso mia
madre con quei racconti che andava sulle
nostre montagne non era un alpinista e
vivendo la montagna ho cominciato a
riflettere a chiedermi chi sono cosa
voglio iniziavo fare i primi passi ad
invertire il mio modo di pensare
cominciavo andare dall'interno verso
l'esterno
iniziavo a relazionarmi a quella parte
del cervello che controlla
il comportamento le azioni e le scelte
terminato il militare mi iscrissi alla
cattolica a scienze motorie 90 posti
94esimo allora andai alla statale e mi
iscrissi alla scuola diretta e fini
speciali di fisioterapia terapista della
riabilitazione ma la voglia di studiare
poka poka a questo 77 iniziali lavorare
all'ospedale di sondalo e un fatto
importante e cambiò la mia esistenza
il mio modo di pensare mi venne
assegnato in quel mese un paziente con
esiti di ictus nel giro di breve breve
tempo riesco a dargli un autonomia di
cammino sono entusiasta del mio lavoro
veramente eroi 7 miceli e venerdì e
allenarti di solito lasciava l'ospedale
dove viveva il convitto per tornarmene
qui nel mio paese prendo la mia 500 nera
e scendo lungo i viali dell'ospedale ma
le macchine sono ferme in colonna corre
voce s'è buttato una persona dalla
finestra incuriosito vado anch'io vedere
e mi accorgo che al mio paziente l'avevo
lasciato 20 minuti prima che camminava
in corridoio crisi totale delusione
fallimento però oggi so che le crisi
possono aiutare a crescere a creare dei
cambiamenti
ero veramente deluso un mese dopo il
primario mi chiamò nel suo studio mi
dice vuoi diventare qualcuno no divisi
non ho voglio solo imparare a fare il
mio lavoro
bene di me dice sappi che se tutti fermi
qui non imparerà mai niente devi girare
il mondo e devi imparare a rubare perché
nessuno ti insegna bene le cose devi
essere critico chiederti perché delle
cose e allora iniziai parti per la
francia
e ancora oggi sto girando il mondo
e o quasi 67 anni e sento sempre bisogno
di apprendere ho sempre bisogno di
imparare e soprattutto ho iniziato in
quel periodo a credere in quello che
facevo e durante quel periodo conobbe
una donna meravigliosa che ho sposato e
dalla quale ho avuto due splendidi figli
che mi hanno sempre supportato ma
soprattutto sopportato e adesso vi
racconto un fatto un fatto che spiega il
perché sono orgoglioso di essere esinese
quando i figli iniziarono le medie venne
forte il desiderio di andare in città io
lavoravo li decidemmo di non cambiare di
rimanere le radici profonde che ho verso
questo luogo le sue tradizioni
i principi di vita semplice che mi sono
stati trasmessi erano sono e fanno parte
di me e tutto questo mi ha permesso di
varcare nuovi confini
infatti questo è l'ultimo progetto che
abbiamo in bolivia dei volontari
fisioterapisti
in questi villaggi sperduti oltre 4000
metri dove lo stato non è presente
e poi anche in african la gente e beveva
quest'acqua è ora invece c'è un pozzo e
quest'anno andremo costruire una serra
ma tutto questo perché perché ho potuto
far assaporare ai miei figli ea tutte le
persone che partecipano a questi
progetti che cosa vuol dire
meravigliarsi che cosa vuol dire capire
le differenze e che cosa vuol dire tare
girando il mondo
ho conosciuto tanti maestri ho imparato
tante tecniche ma era fare qualcosa
sul paziente ma intuivo che c'era
qualcosa d'altro e nel 2003
avevo già 53 anni insegnava
all'università bicocca
incontrai una persona molto importante
nel mondo della fisioterapia shirley sar
ma le parole del mio primario non sempre
li davanti a me vai porta a casa più che
puoi
e allora trovai un collega interprete
perché io non solo inglese è online
negli stati uniti alla washington
university di saint louis
ancora una volta un cambiamento quale
bisogna credere in quello che si fa e
quando tu credi in quello che fai
l'impegno diventa enorme la vita se è
vissuta è un continuo cambiamento
se tu vivacchio sopravvivi tutto si
ferma e credere in quello che fai ti fa
scalare montagne inviolate
infatti con gli amici del cai val
d'esino abbiamo salito una cima della
cordigliera bianca in perù e abbiamo
dato il nome sarro esino 2005 mi viene
consegnato questo pezzo di carta
l'autorizzazione a insegnare in tutto il
mondo disfunzioni del sistema di
movimento
una delle più importanti università
degli stati uniti di fisioterapia che
consegna a me fisioterapista esinese
questo documento mi son detto fantastico
hai avuto molto ora devi dare molto e vi
racconto un po come è cambiata la mia
mentalità di fisioterapista il mio modo
di ragionare
il paziente entra e dice fahmy qualcosa
un mal di schiena fahmy qualcosa con
questo concetto disfunzioni del sistema
di movimento il fisioterapista è la
guida
niente deve diventare il protagonista
del suo problema vi mostro un esempio
vedete questa persona che sale un
gradino e questa tra che sale un gradino
il ginocchio deve essere proiettato sul
secondo dito questo ginocchio non è
proiettato sul secondo dito non è un
movimento fisiologico
c'è qualcosa che non va il dolore
muscoloscheletrico solo il dolore
muscoloscheletrico è dovuto lo stile di
vita come molte malattie metaboliche
se la vostra glicemia sale se il vostro
colesterolo è alto
che cosa può succedere vi sono dei
segnali e cosa dicono questi segnali che
prima o dopo
sarete dei diabetici avrete un ictus
avrete un infarto e se voi vi muovete
come nella figura di sinistra che avete
visto di quel ginocchio quale sarà
risultato dolore al ginocchio la
cartilagine si usura e poi dovrete fare
la protesi il paziente dice ma per me
naturale a muoversi così per me
familiare muoversi così e io gli
rispondo certo per te familiare e
naturale ma non è ottimale non è
fisiologico devi riuscire a trasformare
quello che per te familiare naturale in
maniera che diventi un nuovo familiare
un nuovo ottimale è importante
altrimenti
cosa facciamo se noi prendiamo delle
medicine se noi usiamo delle macchine se
noi usiamo delle tecniche particolari ma
cosa stiamo facendo stiamo curando il
sintomo e creeremo dei dipendenti del
sistema di cura e questo non è più
corretto creare dei dipendenti del
sistema di cura il paziente deve essere
protagonista del suo problema vi dicevo
l'inizio che credo in un sogno quello di
trasmettere insegnando a più colleghi
possibili il messaggio che muoversi bene
è il modo migliore per avere meno dolori
è una carissima collega dalla washington
university linda van dillen una
ricercatrice 2016 ha pubblicato questo
articolo ha dimostrato che muoversi bene
nella giornata è più importante che fare
esercizio terapeutico e come dice la mia
amica shirley sar ma non è cosa fai
ma come segui i tuoi movimenti nella
giornata che è importante e per salire
una montagna inviolata occorre studiare
nei minimi particolari il percorso e
credere in se stessi e in quello che fai
così nell'intricato vivere dei nostri
giorni con i nostri pazienti
la cosa importante è credere in noi
stessi e in ciò che facciamo ma
soprattutto credere nella possibilità
del nostro paziente di cambiare grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]